they've been demonstrating on brazil's
streets for a while now but they're
getting bigger and bigger
the center of sao paulo heaved with
people into the early hours
they're consumed with a hatred of their
president jeremiah
crisis is breaking records here the
infection rates are huge
every day of the week but for many
the fact that half a million people have
died and the country still isn't in
lockdown
or increasing its vaccine program is
just simply too much to take
tens of thousands marched in
well-organized groups watched on by
police
many in riot gear they want bolsonaro
out
and a rethink on how to deal with the
pandemic
for his part president bolsonaro says
the economy has to stay open he says
people might get covered but they'll
definitely starve to death
the trouble is with five hundred
thousand dead and a hundred thousand
people being infected
every single day the economy will
probably just close down anyway
[Music]
the sheer number of people prepared to
start gathering from the afternoon
speaks volumes for their commitment but
also their anger
we didn't meet a single person who
hasn't lost friends and family to covert
we have to to fight because it's
ridiculous
our family is dying people that we love
dying
i can die tomorrow and nothing has been
done so
unfortunately i have to be here
crucially they're from all walks of life
rich and poor
young and old they all want the same
thing bolsonaro out
and they all agree he probably isn't
listening now people are starting to
get angry and start to mobilize to
to show everyone that we don't want this
we don't want to live under the bones on
our government
do you think bolsonaro is going to
listen no but
no he's
he's very alternatory and he don't
listen to people our government decided
that
there is no virus that you have have not
used masks you
can use bad medicines
that's not good for the for the people
and he said there's no matter it's just
a
reflex
[Music]
cities across brazil joined in this mass
protest
the president faces an election next
year with polls showing his popularity
plummeting
in the face of the coveted surge every
day
congressional investigation into the
handling the pandemic
publishes revelations of mismanagement
but at its heart is a president who
doesn't believe in vaccines
masks social distancing or lockdowns or
actually anything
that actually could slow the death rate
down
mr ramsey sky news sao paulo
[Music]